all right perfect um good evening
everyone and good evening manheim uh
this is my
this is also my first time in um
mannheim i'm based out of stuttgart uh
not the most uh not the best place to be
and to be honest
[Laughter]
but well so all right so i'm gonna be
talking about boring stuff today uh so
so i'm gonna set expectations right here
so i'm gonna be talking about asr um asr
is automatic speech recognition so um if
you've ever come across um you know
google um assistant um you know siri um
all sorts of stuff like that
then you have come across asr asr
in its most simplest term
is essentially taking
this speech right whatever i'm saying
right now is taking that and converting
it into um it's time for lunch you know
or essentially converting it into text
right that's that's the main goal of asr
um what i seek to do by the end of this
um this talk is to convince one of you
at least over here to um try and
experiment around some of the models
that i'll be talking about today right
and uh and also try and see if you can
incorporate um you know leveraging this
sort of unstructured data in your you
know day-to-day job so um if one of you
do that that will be great tweet out to
me i'm at reach underscore vb um
all right let's get the let's get let's
get to the fun stuff right so um what is
um automatic speech recognition right so
i have some sort of a uh some sort of a
waveform i um take that and i convert it
into text
right
sounds easy right sounds simple it's
it's just taking you know some some
audio file uh and then just um
essentially getting some text out of it
we have a a billion models out there
there are you know insane number of um
research labs working on this then
what's the complicated bit here right um
let's try and see this um a bit more in
detail right
um
like
why is it not so um
um
simple what you see on the screen right
now um is a spectrogram or rather is the
waveform representation of three words
uh the first one is red the second one
is yell and the third one is ben three
words right
simple words that we um say every now
and then um now if if i was talking
about asr if i was just talking about a
machine learning model right i was just
talking about an algorithm which takes
some sort of speech in processes it and
um you know gives me some text out
then
then
that particular model would fail in this
scenario can anyone tell me why
i think because we have uh
phonetics and we have geography of
geographical representation
exactly yes so um
the the way we we deal with um sound is
very different than the way we deal with
say text or numbers numbers are numbers
are unique so one would always be one in
any language in any geography in any um
in in any sort of situation same same as
text so my name vb would be vb in in in
any context whatsoever however if if i
vbb who is an indian if i say something
in german my pronunciation would be very
different than you know alex saying the
same thing in german right um of course
he would be more charming in that
but um but sure right so the way the way
we pronounce things is different um the
way anyone says things is different and
and varies a lot right let's take for
example good morning i can say good
morning or i can say good morning right
or i can say good morning right i can i
can say it in n number of different ways
now if this was an algorithm um how
would you like how would you try and
reconcile all of these different
different variations to a good morning
so that's what that's what we're going
to try and sort of see or like that's
what we're going to try and unravel in
the next couple of
minutes or well
at least we'll see where we get to um
what we see on the screen right now is
um different variations of
right so the so the
in the in the word red you see it's it's
like red so like the variation of eh is
a sort of more like it goes above like
you you have more more sort of emphasis
as you save it uh same in case of yell
it starts off at a high note and then
goes down in case of then it's it's not
the same
believe it or not this is still the same
sort of phonetic element so it's it's
still a right so all of all three of
these correspond to the same character
correspond to the same text um
so that's what makes it tough right
let's look at another variation so now
what you look at is um
four words this is
right the all of these simple words um
with different context we have different
sort of waveforms right so i i hope by
now you you understand that context in
this case matters a lot right and and
what you also understand is that it's
not as simple as just like writing an if
statement saying that if you see a
pattern like this say that it is this
character right it's a it's a it's a bit
more uh nuanced than that
now let's let's see how sort of modern
architectures look at this let's see how
um how our previous generation solved
this problem
uh as well so a quick blast from the
past um how we previously used to do it
was we had some sort of a speech right
and we would we would get some sort of
features out of it these features in um
in most cases were mfcc features if you
don't know what mfcc is um
think of mfcc features as a black box
you you you get different sort of um
different composition of the speech
itself over time right so you have
different things like how
how um loud was the sound what was the
pitch of the sound and so on and so
forth right assume those as features
then you would pass it through a
perceptron which is nothing but a um you
know like a very simple neural network
and you would get probabilities right
these probabilities would be hey this
particular um
waveform corresponds to the letter a
corresponds with letter b corresponds to
the letter c with 90 probability with 10
probability and with zero percent
probability and so on right um that's
that's it that's that's how we used to
do it before and then you know we used
to use some sort of fancy um hmms and we
used to get a sequence out however
this did not scale well this was one
time consuming this was too um uh you
know to this require too much of effort
and you know compute for um for us to
sort of you know build um uh build and
you know like run and so on and you know
more often than not it was just slow
right and also it was like imagine this
like for for every transcription you're
just like running this algorithm again
and again and again and again and again
and then like getting a sequence out um
and you know plain and simple this is
boring right uh let's let's try and make
this more fun
so this did not scale well and um that
is why we did not have city back in
1980s um sorry about that uh
but
yeah um let's see what what do we do now
right so now we still have the same
waveform um we have the same waveform so
we still have the same sort of sound
wave which says it's time for barbecue
the hints at alex for barbecue uh and
then we we we have some sort of future
um computation so we again get like
different sort of um composition of the
waveform so we get uh male spectrogram
per frame you know we we get how loud it
is we get how uh what's the pitch and uh
you know a couple different things um
around this and we pass it to an to an
encoder now what is an encoder an
encoder is again a neural network which
tries to um
tries to understand
uh what has been passed to it right so
in the most simplest terms it basically
understands the context of what's passed
to it right so if it was a waveform it
would try to connect different you know
words um with
individual words within the within the
waveform and
it essentially helps us
to solve this problem wherein you know
for different characters i have
different variations so it tries to
learn these variations so so that every
time you know there is an in between w
and d it would um uh you know it would
say that hey this is this is eh right so
that's what the encoder learns um
essentially and then we we get to the
decoder stage and uh decoder basically
says hey you know this particular 10
millisecond um
um you know waveform corresponds to i
the other one corresponds to t and and
so on and so forth and through this
encoder decoder architecture we get the
um we get the output which is it's time
for barbecue um and so on so that's
um that's basically it that's that's how
like modern architectures of of asl work
however um as i as i mentioned um if
this would have been solved by now i
wouldn't be here talking about it right
so there are definitely multiple
problems um with this now let's look at
um two of these key problems and how do
we solve this in academia um right now
and um
in production as well
so um the first problem is um a single
word might be just five letters long but
it may take two seconds so um you know
take for example food you know food um
when i just say the word food it could i
i can say the word food just in you know
uh less than a second or i can just be
like food
right or i can be like uh dude where's
the food right i i can say it as fast as
possible i can say it as slow as
possible i can i can say it in different
variations and uh different dialects of
the language would support um would have
different ways of saying it as well
right so what this means is that the
same uh that the same five letters might
take different time over here you know
so
when i'm when i'm decoding like my my
input still remains the same but my
decoding at the time of decoding i might
have you know different variations of
this transcription so how do i how do i
deal with that right um or or rather how
do i deal with different dialects how do
i deal with different demographics or
how do i deal with different lengths of
waveforms which all correspond to the
same text right
um the way we do that
right now is by just concatenating
different features so you know i i take
the i i split the waveform into 10
millisecond snippets and i concatenate
sort of um the the previous vector the
next vector together and i and i passed
like
and i passed three sort of um
um
three feature sets together so
we go back to the same example over here
so in this case i will pass the 10
milliseconds of w the 10 milliseconds of
f and the 10 milliseconds of t all
together to the to the waveform so that
it gets more context and you know um it
is it is able to
um sort of process faster so it's not
slow right um and and then hopefully it
gets more context as well and you know
we we we get to its time um and so on
right um
so this is still simple like all i have
to do in my code is just like
essentially change two things and you
know i will i will still be able to get
a transcription um
but
how do we v meaning the the model itself
know which part of x which is the audio
maps to which part of i so how do we
know in this example in this waveform uh
which part of this waveform corresponds
to i which part of this waveform
corresponds to t which part of this uh
waveform corresponds to s and so on like
that's like think of it this way like a
model is
the model does not have any other
information than just the waveform
itself right so how does the model sort
of figure out um which
section which subsection of the of the
waveform corresponds to what right um
and that that is a literally a billion
dollar question there's there's an
entire metadata like meta ai team which
just focuses on that there is like
google ai research speech team which
just focuses on that and so on and i'm
gonna give you like one such example and
i'm gonna give you some um code bases
that you can look at as well as some
demos uh through which you can like play
around with it in just two minutes about
it
but remember the
the problem here is that we want to
figure out which part of the audio
or audio wave form corresponds to which
text right the billion dollar question
um
the way we do that from uh from both
like an academic standpoint as a lesser
research standpoint is by using
something called connectionist temporal
classification
don't worry i'm gonna i'm gonna break
this down
so what what ctc does is that instead of
me saying
this part of the waveform
belongs to the word
it or belongs to the word bbq
um what it does is it splits the entire
waveform into 10 milliseconds and tries
to get one output for each of those
right so for so if if i have a one
second long clip it would break it down
into 10 milliseconds and for each 10
millisecond snippet it would try to get
one character output out right um
and and and then it tries to sort of
find a fun way to um collapse at all and
and get a letter um if that did not make
sense up until now it will make sense in
the next slide
um
so
what you see over here is
is an example of how ctc works right so
we have the input which is a 14
millisecond sorry um a 140 millisecond
input so a 140 millisecond waveform we
split that into um you know 14 snippets
so like 10 millisecond each snippet uh
x1 x2 x3 x4 this goes into the whole
encoder decoder thing that we spoke
about right
um and and then for for for each of
these input it tries to give me one
output so the first x1 belongs to d
the the second x2 belongs to i the third
one
uh you know maybe did not have any sound
so it just gave it like a null character
um the fourth one belongs to n and so on
and so forth right so so this in this
context was something like dinner right
so that's how this was said um and it's
it's transcription would be like in the
in the first phase would be that i get
uh individual character outputs and then
what what ctc does is it merge
duplicates right so you see that there
was d i then there was um
like
no voice then there was two ends those
two ends got collapsed right and now i
have n and then there was a break there
was another n then there was e and then
there were four r's they all got
collapsed to r
and then break right so what's happened
here um is essentially we mapped a large
feature space so a 140 millisecond
feature space down to a world dinner
right and uh um this is how we sort of
solve the problem of varying time frames
so now you can say something like dna
and it would still give you dinner right
hopefully you won't say it like that uh
but if you do then the then there is way
to solve for it right
and uh
what this also sort of helps with is
that
irrespective of how you say it would be
able to run you know learn all of these
you know multiple alignments and still
be able to produce the same
transcription so all the different
transcriptions you say over here like
see over here
have the same um
you know
half the same output which is dinner
because all of these collapse into the
same thing and
um
you know uh to be honest when when i
started researching this was the bit
which which which basically made me fell
in love with with the whole research
kind of uh
side of speech and uh it's it's honestly
just four lines of code that's it i i i
have it like later on um for uh for a
brief demo you can look at it or you can
you know chat about it with me um
afterwards as well um but basically this
this like this four five line of code is
is what solved
um or like got siri on your iphones is
what got google assistant on your um you
know um android phones and so on and so
forth um
and and that's how like asr essentially
works right so
just to like summarize break your
waveform into small pieces for each
waveform get some sort of a
character output and then collapse them
right that's it um
what um
now that we've sort of done the like
we've gone through like some sort of
like theoretical part of it what is the
current state of the art what what what
is the facebook of the world what is the
google of the world uh using right now
um on their phones like on their on
their applications so there is wave to
wake 2.0 uh there is data to work i i
have linked the papers but essentially
what they what they do is and this is a
bit beyond the scope of the stock is
they use transformer type architectures
um to uh and you know mast audio
modeling to learn asr um there is
conformer which is a convolutional
augmented transformer and then there is
context net which is a which is a sort
of slightly old network um before the
sort of transformer error and um all of
these still work right
and
in case you want to try these out you
know in action then you can you can try
these out um on hugging face um
right now so i can i can i can actually
give you a demo
of this um i have linked this in my
um in my slides as well so what we have
right now is a small audio file which
says something like
i don't know if we have audio here
though
oh
crap uh anyway um so
like i can i can share the link to this
uh in a bit but but basically what this
demo does is you can you can basically
record any sort of
um audio uh over here you can you can
actually just actually let's let's let's
try and record something
um
okay
um hello my name is weeby
i don't know if that worked uh
let's see it's it's sort of like um
trying to
oh it gave an error
of course why would the demo work um in
the first place but anyway i uh because
i knew that this would not work so i
have a cached demo um already which says
uh something like hey it's time for
boiled potatoes or something like that
uh you know the usual stuff that you say
to your friends uh
but
um but essentially what this what this
does is it it uses the ctc algorithm
that i said um with the with different
variations and
tries to get like you know it's its
intended transcription out
and uh and what's what's um uh like
what's what's happening here is it is
using the same
um
the same sort of state-of-the-art um
architecture which i um which i spoke
about earlier which is wave to wait 2.0
which is currently the best um out there
and
yeah um you can so you can of course try
that out you can also like you can also
try these models out directly on hugging
face so you can go on the links uh below
these these are open source so you can
use them for for for any of your
um
for any of your dev related activities
and so on so um just just feel free to
sort of plug plug and play these you
don't have to sort of pay for any of
these all of these are available for
free um
and
that's about it uh thank you so much for
for tuning in for my talk i hope i did
not bore you that much uh and if you
have any questions related to speech
related to audio uh feel free to find me
after this or you can tweet out to me at
reached underscore vb or you can email
me
i respond to pretty much every email
that i get and i love chatting about
boring stuff
so thank you so much
you